[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo le magazine des temps
forts à l'assemblée et au sénat avec tam
bonjour katia est notre invité cette
semaine et le député la république en
marche de paris sylvain maillard bonjour
bonjour et vous allez revenir avec nous
sur l'actualité parlementaire de la
semaine prévient avec d'abord un débat
tendu à l'assemblée nationale sur le
traité c'est à qui prévoit d'ouvrir le
marché entre l'union européenne et le
canada l'opposition de droite comme de
gauche dénonce un texte dangereux pour
la france
le vote solennel sur ce texte aura lieu
le 23 juillet prochain
le sénat a subi l'ondé de choc de la
sphère de rugy sa démission est
intervenue deux heures avant le début de
l'examen du projet de loi sur l'énergie
et le climat à la chambre haute
elisabeth borgne a dû reprendre le texte
au pied levé dans un hémicycle très
agacé cette semaine une mission s'est
penché sur le coût économique et social
du mouvement des gilet jaune la facture
est lourde et ce sont les petites
entreprises aux abords des
manifestations qui ont le plus souffert
c'est l'un des constats de ce rapport et
puis la cour de cassation a validé le
barème maquereau et le plafonnement des
indemnités prud'homale la veille un
rapport sénatorial critiqué cette
justice entre employeurs et salariés
bien trop lente et pas assez
professionnel selon les sénateurs est
d'abord le sujet qui a animé l'hémicycle
cette semaine la discussion très tendue
du c'est à cet accord de libre échange
qui prévoit de libéraliser les échanges
entre l'union européenne et le canada
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est 15h mercredi 17 juillet les
députés entame la discussion du projet
de ratification du ceta la séance sera
finalement levé à 2h40 signe que les
discussions ont été très tendues
compte-rendu séance avec clément
perreault dramatiser les enjeux mettre
la majorité face à sa responsabilité
devant l'histoire
c'est la stratégie de l'opposition dans
l'hémicycle c'est l'appel que je lance
aux députés de la majorité
vous ne pouvez pas vous accrocher à une
théorie économique aujourd'hui qui est
bougies les individus qui bousillent la
planète
une théorie économique qui est d'un
autre temps je suis sûr que le soir nue
entre vaudra dans le silence de vos
consciences
vous êtes comme inquiet angoissée pour
vos enfants qui est en cause désormais
c'est un effondrement de l'espace de
sécurité dans lequel la vie humaine a pu
se développer sur terre vous proposez
vous d'appuyer sur l'accélérateur au
canada tous les animaux peuvent être
nourris grâce à des farines animales
or cannibalisme cela veut dire
concrètement qu'un boeuf peut être
nourri à la farine animale
créé à partir de restes de cheval ou de
porc par exemple ce même boeuf qui peut
être nourris à base de farine créé à
partir de protéines issues de gélatine
provenant de la peau de ruminants de
s'enfuir de son 100 ou 200 gr fondu
stratégie inverse bien sûr pour les
ministres et députés de la majorité qui
cherchent à rassurer à tout prix
aucune importation nouvelle n'est
autorisée par l'accord et les normes
européennes continueront de s'appliquer
on a parlé des saumons ogm on a parlé de
l'invasion de boeuf aux hormones du
saumon ogm il n'y en aura pas du boeuf
aux hormones il n'y en aura pas plus si
le canada un jour devait sortir des
accords de paris et bien c'est très
simple
l'article 30.9 du ceta prévoit une
procédure une clause de dénonciation ces
débats seront finalement conclue par un
vote solennel réclamé à cor et à cri par
l'opposition
il aura lieu mardi prochain après des
questions au gouvernement
sylvain mayer vous avez suivi ce débat
les oppositions compte des doutes dans
la majorité finalement cela s'ouvre pas
comme sous de très bons auspices
d'abord il faut redire que c'est un
accord qui est déjà en en vigueur depuis
deux ans et donc par rapport à une
discussion de ce qui peut arriver en
fait on voit déjà ce qui arrive très
clairement il est bénéficiaire pour
l'ensemble de l'europe à plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros y est pour
la france aussi beaucoup de nos produits
entre autres alimentaires se sont
largement vendus et continueront à se
vendre au canada et donc il est
largement bénéfique et puis on a une
opposition qui s'est clairement league
et sur nes et réserve certaine
opposition qu'on a entendues sur la
viande nourri aux hormones sur les
farines animales
par exemple en fait je pense qu'il ya du
fantasme il ya en politique ça fait
partie aussi des postures et puis à du
fantasme et je crois que c'est vraiment
du fantasme c'est à dire que le ceta
prévoit d'appliquer exactement les mêmes
règles qu'avant le ceta rien ne change
et donc évidemment tout ce qui était
interdit avant le ceta reste un terrain
pour vous ce qui fait qu militante les
hommes tous et ou non je ne crois qu'il
ya une angoisse tout simplement de dire
on va importer de la malbouffe
on va on va apporter donc on va
multiplier les échanges et on va penser
foule pour vous ça et c'est faux et ça a
été largement démontrée d'abord dans les
faits depuis deux ans parce qu'il n'y a
absolument aucun changement par bonds
avant et que ce qui est interdit en
europe selon nos normes nos critères
sont pas toujours les mêmes que qu'au
canada ce qui est interdit en europe
restent interdits et les canadiens ne
peuvent pas exporter vers l'europe
ces produits les produits carnés
principalement l on est donc donc voilà
que en matière environnementale un
toutes les ong de défense de
l'environnement qui ne sont pas
convaincus non plus par le csa fait
beaucoup d'opposants à ceux à ce traité
libre échange
moi j'entends très clairement il ya une
opposition d'ailleurs
à philosophique entre une parti
écologiste qui veut une décroissance
très clairement une décroissance et une
partie est ce que nous portons donc
profondément à la république en marche
c'est psychologique avec une croissance
une croissance verte une croissance
verte c'est 2-2 de conception de
l'économie qui sont totalement
différentes et donc on les mélange
souvent avec elle en parlant d'écologie
mais c'est deux choses totalement
différentes et donc dire qu'on ne veut
plus de commerce international c'est
quoi enfin je parle pas à parapher
paraphraser une une phrase célèbre mais
c'est du protectionnisme
le protectionnisme c'est la guerre si on
a on continue pas les échanges on
démultiplie pas les échanges ça veut
dire quoi sert qu on se recroqueville
on perd des emplois et ça finit par du
protectionnisme et le protectionnisme
normale et le renouveau lagarde ce qui
est des volontés de contrôle etc
mais tout à fait mais sachez que la
crainte est aussi de notre côté et se
dire ainsi on ne démultiplie pas les
échanges
on ne construit pas une croissance pour
tous pour tous les êtres humains sur
cette planète si on n'arrive pas à créer
de la croissance pour tous mais quelque
part on se met en difficulté on se met
en danger et on sait toujours comment ça
se termine
on a entendu les oppositions sur tous
les bancs de l'hémicycle contre ce texte
lors de ce débat très long il ya aussi
eu des réserves au sein même de la
majorité
est ce que vous pensez qu'il y aura des
abstentions au sein de la république en
marche lors du vote solennel prévu le 23
juillet à l'assemblée
je crois que chacun d'entre nous et âme
à un moment face à ses responsabilités
et fasse aussi à ce qu'il pense
profondément
la vertu de ce débat qui est l on vous
l'avait dit plus long que ce que l'on
pense que ce que nous avions envisagé
c'est aussi de faire naître des
arguments un argumentaire d'un côté
comme de l'autre qui a pu faire évoluer
aussi au sein de notre majorité
on verra on va voir comment chacun se
positionne ait eu des positions assez
dur évidemment contre le sida y compris
chez des députés est chez nous mais
c'est vraiment très minoritaire soyons
soyons honnêtes dessus et puis enfin il
y aura un vote solennel c'est nous qui
avons demandé le vote solennel aux qui
passera
il exploite je n'ai pas d'inquiétude
dessus mais surtout c'est un vote sous
la main c'est quelque chose d'important
qui nous oblige chacun d'entre nous à
nous positionner et et ne pas avoir un
vote à 3 heures du matin après la
question gouvernance et voilà mais il
n'était pas seul vote était prévu à 3
heures en fin à la fuite
et c'est évidemment trop tard sylvain
maillard le ceta n'est pas le seul
traité de libre échange assez à grincer
des dents au sénat les agriculteurs ont
aussi largement critiquée et bien
l'accord conclu entre l'union européenne
et le mercosur regardez aujourd'hui
c'est un jeu de dupes
c'est un jeu de dupes je ne peux pas le
dire autrement est ce que les contrôles
vont être fait ou pas les brésiliens
vont nous dire oui oui nous on fait des
contrôles l'europe à nous dire oui les
contrôles sont pas faits bon ce qu'on
peut vous dire c'est ce que j'ai redit
avant on sait qu'à des documents
officiels qui ont été falsifiés on sait
qu'il ya des pots de vin le ministre
enfin une partie de l'administration a
été inculpé au brésil je commande en
négociant des pays où les protocoles de
contrôle de contre-pouvoir et de
transparence ne sont pas les mêmes ne
sont pas les mêmes que dans nos pays
développés
c'est fort un ce que dit cet agriculteur
c'est un jeu de dupes
comment s'assurer que le produit qui
arrive en france seront réellement
contrôler ses produits en provenance du
markosian quand on connaît les fraudes
qu'il ya déjà là-bas c'est là où
l'actualité parfois se mélangent et nous
fait faire ou penser ou dire ou avoir
des votes des positions qui sont pas
tenables
le cétacé évidemment avec le canada qui
a les mêmes normes ont pas forcément
qu'elles mêmes normes d'hygiène mêmes
normes de fonctionnement de vie de deux
sociétés est évidemment avec le mercosur
alors on est dans sur un autre notre
idée ou une autre cadencement en tout
cas ce qui est certain c'est que ça
comme les négociations ont commencé il
ya 20 ans il ya vingt ans la contrainte
écologie la contrainte de l'alimentation
et de la qualité de l'alimentation c'est
des choses qui n'existaient pas ou très
peu et donc évidemment elles n'ont été
peu ou pas du tout intégré dans la
négociation dans le mercosur ont
beaucoup plus de crainte donc avec
l'histoire ont changé le hall est en
négociation tellement l'oncle et vous
comprendrez ccra
évidemment mais on les partage est donc
d'abord on n'avait pas le texte sur la
table
personne ne la lui en tout cas tout cas
c'est pas mon cas nous n'avons pas eu le
texte sur la table et on voit bien que
il y aura forcément renégociation latif
sur ces points qui ont été soulevées et
qui sont justifiés juste y est
clairement justifié
on passe au deuxième thème de l'émission
au sénat le projet de loi sur l'énergie
et le climat très perturbé par la
démission de françois de rugy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce texte phare en matière de politique
énergétique a été défendue mardi par la
secrétaire d'état emmanuelle wargon
avant que ce soit elisabeth bornes qui
prennent le relais le lendemain
agacement dans l'hémicycle du sénat
récit par adrien de volée alors que les
sénateurs attendait françois de rugy
dans l'hémicycle coup de théâtre le
ministre de la transition écologique
annonce sa démission du gouvernement
deux heures avant le début de la
discussion du texte c'est finalement la
secrétaire d'état emmanuelle wargon qui
se présente face aux sénateurs
un remplacement au pied levé commenté le
pompon et l'apothéose la démission d'un
ministre
à deux heures du début de l'examen de ce
texte
madame la secrétaire d'état je vous
remercie d'être là c'est une forme
d'héroïsme de votre part la discussion
du texte commence
mais le lendemain nouveau changement de
casting la passation de pouvoirs à peine
terminée elisabeth bornes se présentent
au sénat une nouvelle ministre pour un
texte crucial
ce qui ne manque pas d'agacer ce projet
il a été commencé par le ministre
nicolas hulot il a été présenté par le
ministre d origine suite à sa démission
au lierre on a commencé la dg avec avec
mme emmanuelle wargon et aujourd'hui
nous allons continuer l'examen avec
elisabeth board est d'emblée la nouvelle
ministre est attaqué sur le train
perpignan rungis la ligne de fret
menacé d'être fermée l'année prochaine
est déserté par les clients qui lui
préfèrent des camions c'est ahurissant
d'aucuns conviendra campus d'être
économiquement absurde
cette opération est écologiquement
irresponsable alors vous nous reprochez
de faire rouler un train vide qu'est ce
que vous nous auriez dit si ce train
s'était arrêté son passage des
transports à la transition écologique
laisse certains sénateurs sceptiques
jugé par quelques uns trop techno et
trop peu écolo par d'autres mais les
abeilles borne n'a sur son engagement
écologique ne date pas d'hier
sylvain maillard pas assez techno pas
assez écolo qu'est ce que vous pensez
des critiques qui sont faites à la
nouvelle ministre de la transition
écologique
moi je crois que c'est un bon choix
c'est pas forcément le choix qui était
attendu et je crois que c'est un bon
choix parce qu'elle connaît parfaitement
les sujets l est
e ministre depuis plus de deux ans elle
a été directrice de cabinet en deux
ségolène royal et l'on connaît
parfaitement les sujets moi j'ai
travaillé avec elle il ya quelques
semaines sur la loi mobilité avec des
positions que j'ai essayé de faire
valoir et je crois sur certains pour les
parisiens qui fut bien les dossiers sur
les trottinettes entre autres de
trottinettes électriques et sur d'autres
sujets sur le travail et le travail paie
plus et c'est une ministre qui est à l'
écoute qui est ce n'est pas une figure a
en tout cas on est loin de nicolas hulot
et avancer ces dossiers que très
clairement qui fait avancer ces dossiers
là et qui part non puisqu'on parle de
l'actualité parlementaire qui parle avec
les députés qui parle avec les sénateurs
qui comprend ce qui même si on n'est pas
d'accord qui échangent le profondément
on n'a pas toujours eu le cas vous
parlait nicolas hulot n'a pas toujours
eu cet échange est peut-être ça c'est ce
qui est aussi à fragiliser les dépôts
n'est toi c'est quoi la qualité numéro
un pour faire un bon bonne ministre de
la transition écologique pour la qualité
je pense qu'il faut des qualités vocales
du soleil la lune et il faut évidemment
un carnet et parce que les deux dossiers
et qu'il écoute et et d'être très
pragmatique je crois que l'écologie
d'annonce l'écologie de plateau je crois
que c'est quelque chose derrière nous
c'est concrètement souvent quand même
beaucoup par les déclarations des trains
perpignan louis moinet interpeller tout
de suite sur celle d'aller le voir avec
benjamin griveaux il ya quelques
quelques semaines
pour le train directement à rungis parce
que c'est quelque chose de fondamental
permettre des camions elle s'en est
saisie sans qu'elle ait pas de vide
immense mais non c'est en fait il ya eu
beaucoup de parlementaires qui jugent
qu'elle est responsable de cette
situation
koné tiassé ne connaissent pas le
dossier ils ne connaissent pas le
dossier la réalité c'est qu'il n'a eu
aucun investissement sur cette ligne
depuis des années et donc on hérite
d'une situation où le train ne peut plus
circuler ou dans des conditions pérenne
et donc il faut réinvestir plus de 20
millions sur cette ligne nous avons dit
que nous allons le faire à la ministre
de le mettre en oeuvre
elle était ministre des transports de la
troupe des annonces de député ou de
sénateur qui n'est qu'ils n'y
connaissent absolument rien et qui n'ont
pas suivi et pour certains d'entre eux
qui sont là depuis longtemps qu'il
n'avait pas suivi ce dossier il aurait
mieux fait de mettre un peu plus la
pression sur la sncf et à quelques
années est ce que vous comprenez tout de
même la lassitude dessinateur qui en ont
assez de tous ces changements de casting
sur un seul et même texte en termes de
coordination c'est compliqué oui bien
évidemment je me mets à la place
de mes collègues parlementaires c'est
vrai que c'est pas très agréable d'avoir
d'avoir une texte qui n'est pas suivi
par le même ministre a écouté c'est la
vie parlementaire
on sait très bien que la vie des
ministres était ainsi faite qu'il ya du
changement et que ça peut arriver deux
heures à montech ce qui est essentiel
c'est que il est bien un ministre qui
représente au gouvernement au banc et
puis ce sont des ministres de qualité
qui diront personne n'a attaqué la
qualité tennis vous allez bien quelques
changements c'est ça aussi la continuité
de l'état
sas incarne comme ça alors que l'inde
ailleurs quel est le coût économique et
social du mouvement des gilet jaune
question qui était posée cette semaine à
l'assemblée nationale la mission
parlementaire qui travaillait sur le
sujet a rendu son rapport les petits
commerces situés le long des cortèges de
manifestations payer le prix fort du
mouvement c'est l'une des conclusions
des députés qui ont mené l enquête mari
la bat l'impact du mouvement des gilet
jaune sur les ronds-points dans les
centres villes chaque samedi pendant 9
mois est considérable pour les commerces
et l'état c'est en tout cas ce que
conclut le rapport remis ce matin par
damien abad
jean rené cazeneuve et roland lescure
les trois députés confirment le coût
global donné voilà quelques jours par
bruno le maire de 0,1 point de pib au
dernier trimestre de l'année 2018
ça peut sembler peu c'est quand même
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
sur tout ce qui est important c'est que
c'est la partie visible de l'iceberg et
que derrière cette partie visible il ya
toute une partie émergée qui est bien
plus grave plus en plus importante et
surtout dans des circonscriptions dans
les localités particulière qui ont été
évidemment bien plus affecté que la
france dans sa moyenne
concrètement la mission parlementaire a
évalué le montant de plusieurs préjudice
au premier rang desquels les pertes
enregistrées par les centres commerciaux
à hauteur de 2 milliards d'euros
les commerces des centres villes eux ont
perdu 20 à 30% de leur chiffre
d'affaires
l'état aussi dû faire face à des
dépenses de plus de 46 millions d'euros
au titre des heures supplémentaires
effectuées par les forces de l'ordre
71 millions d'euros pour la remise en
état des près de trois mille radars
détruits ou abîmés
les députés ont par ailleurs évalué
l'impact direct du mouvement sur le
budget de certaines villes
particulièrement touchés et la facture
est élevée 10 millions d'euros pour
paris 7 million et demi pour toulouse
plus de trois millions pour bordeaux et
près de 2 millions d'euros pour roy
voilà pour ce premier bilan alors les
deux rapporteurs sont issus de la
majorité le président de la mission est
de droite est ce que pour vous c'est un
rapport à charge un rapport anti gilet
jaune si l'on peut dire
moi je crois que c'est la vérité très
clairement
vous savez moi je suis le député du
centre de paris des champs elysées des
grands boulevards au delà de des
magasins qui ont été cassés
quand il s'en viennent kong a été
touchée d'actes mans pendant des
semaines et dès samedi et dès samedi
au delà de ceux qui ont été cassés qui
sont finalement et heureusement assez
peu nombreux donc c'est un bilan jugé
que la réalité c'est beaucoup d'entre
eux beaucoup de commerces n'ont pu
travailler le samedi fermé leurs
magasins le samedi c'est le meilleur
journée donc l'impact économique je
crois plus chiffré à 2 milliards
peut-être est même plus important et
c500 terme d'image oscille entre
l'animation des deux touristes on a
moins 35 % de touristes à part ça oui je
crois je crois que c'est important la
ministre moi j'ai fait des tournées avec
agnès pannier rue n'achète pour aller
voir les petits commerces et puis mettre
en place aussi tout ce qu'on tout ce
qu'on a pu apporter c'est à dire
évidemment un report de charge mais
aussi une exonération pour ceux qui ont
été le plus touchés des charges parce
qu'il y en a qui ne pousse qui allait
peut être fermé on en est à des
difficultés pareil
compass été cassée mais qui ont été
tellement impact et où par exemple les
policiers fermer la rue et donc aucun
client ne peut accéder une fois que les
clients ont perdu l'habitude de venir
acheter où on voit bien l'habitude de
venir par exemple à paris le samedi eh
ben pour ses commerces assez d'une
catastrophe
ça doit pas toujours dans les chiffres
officiels la gauche à boycotter ce
rapport à ce que vous comprenez la
position de la gauche voilà ils ont une
position purement idéologique en disant
écoutez si on montre que effectivement
ça a eu un impact ça risque de
d'anéantir ce que les messages comporter
du rapport
on est du coup subjective en disant on
sait ce qui va y avoir dans la ne pas se
rendre compte que les commerçants ont
perdu énormément d'argent que les villes
ont ça leur coûte énormément d'argent
c'est eux qui sont vraiment la
subjectivité voilà ils veulent pas un
rapport ou s'associer un rapport qui
montre la réalité de ce qui a été le
mouvement des gilet jaune
c'est en tout cas une de ses réalités
ses rapports provisoires ou penser que
la facture peut s'alourdir si on refait
un bilan du mouvement dans quelques mois
moi j'en suis persuadé par ces sont
évanouies et en terme d'image et moi je
l'élu parisien qui vous parle en terme
d'image évidemment ça impacte ses
impacts aussi les réservations pour cet
été
les hôtels ne sont pas remplies et
probablement ça va durer encore un peu
de temps parce que le temps de relancer
la machine
ça prend du temps oui sur un impact
encore plus important on continue la
semaine le sénat demande aux prud'hommes
plus d'efficacité
[Musique]
à la veille de la décision très attendue
de la cour de cassation sur les barèmes
macron un rapport ce matériel a appelé à
réformer la justice prud'homale
c'est un paradoxe le nombre de
contentieux est en baisse pourtant et
bien allez toujours aussi lente
les sénateurs formule 46 propositions
pour fluidifier la procédure
explications alizée boissin il faut
attendre parfois plus de deux ans le
délai de jugement des prud'hommes
dépasse largement les autres
juridictions
et pourtant le nombre d'affaires lui
diminue pour inverser la tendance
le groupe de travail du sénat formule
des propositions dont certaines
pourraient toucher les salariés qui se
rendent aux prud'hommes parmi elles
l'étape de la conciliation
aujourd'hui obligatoire le fait que la
conciliation ne soit plus une obligation
mais bien un outil repérer si nous
allons en conciliation
il y aura effectivement des délais moins
longs
une conciliation facultatif donc mais
l'urgence pour les sénatrices se trouve
aussi dans la formation
en effet les conseillers prud'homaux ne
sont pas des professionnels du droit
il ya un début de professionnalisation
qui était mis en place avec le
recrutement des nouveaux conseillers et
la formation professionnelle initiale et
un certain nombre de procédures nous
souhaitons aller beaucoup plus loin
notamment avec eux plus de fluidité plus
de lien avec les magistrats
professionnels
le rapport propose alors l'obligation
d'une formation continue pour les
conseillers sous la responsabilité de
l'école nationale de la magistrature
enfin pour parer le manque de
crédibilité de la justice prud'homale
les sénatrices joue sur les symboles à
la place du port de la médaille elle
demande le port de la robe pour les
conseillers prud'homaux ou encore le
changement de nom des conseils de
prud'hommes en tribunal
si les indications du rapport ne sont
pas reprises par le gouvernement une
proposition de loi pourrait voir
rapidement le jour
est-ce que vous aussi vous jugé qu'
aujourd'hui bien les juges aux
prud'hommes ne sont pas assez
professionnel et que dans l'ensemble ce
système manque d'efficacité je vous
donnais mon expérience c'est mon chiot
en même temps je suis député mais aussi
chef d'entreprise donc je suis allé
aussi aux prud'hommes un moment ou un
autre ça rime
dans une vie professionnelle et je crois
qu'il ya beaucoup de bonne volonté de la
part des conseillers prud'homaux mais
très clairement il manque des moyens et
de formation
il ya un côté un peu amateur par rapport
à ce que l'on peut connaître dans notre
le reste de notre justice froid qui a
été parfaitement mentionnés par les
sénateurs il faut qu'on avance dessus on
a eu cette semaine vous l'avez dit le
barème là mais en tout cas la cour de
cassation qui a validé le barème
prud'homale qui permet aussi d'éviter
bon nombre de contentieux parce que
l'employeur c'est ce qu'il va payer et
donc la négociation est plus rapide et
le salarié c'est ce à quoi il a le droit
et je crois que pour le regarde et me
disent les syndicats à distance sécurisé
les employeurs fautifs
au contraire c'est un cadeau au patronat
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je pense
qu'en fait ils ne connaissent pas les
situations moi je pense que quand un
salarié et se retrouve dans cette
situation s'il n'y a pas eu évidemment
des cas très graves
il ya une discrimination s'il ya eu du
harcèlement ça ça rentre pas dans le
barème mais la réalité c'est que le
salarié ne sait pas que ce à quoi il a
droit et donc parfois avec eux quelques
avocats autour de lui se disent
peut-être j'ai gagné le jackpot et
partent dans une dans une procédure que
finalement ils maîtrisent pas moi je
crois que c'est important que ça évite
que le salarié touche rapidement son
chèque
on dit puisse repartir dans une vie dans
une eau une autre un autre métier et que
l'entreprise puisse aussi passer à autre
chose sur de nouveaux projets parce que
ce sera pour moi gagnant gagnant on le
voit très clairement yann beaucoup moins
de deux recours aux prud'hommes ce sont
des mesures que vous pourriez voter si
elle était reprise dans le cadre d'une
proposition de loi ici à l'assemblée
par principe le lit d'abord ce qui est
proposé puis après je viendrai vous
donner mon avis final est plutôt bien
évidemment évidemment tout cas très
clairement il faut une
professionnalisation plus importante
également c'est pour vous un soulagement
cette histoire de de validation par la
cour de cassation du barème des
indemnités prud'homale sachant qu'il y
avait un certain nombre de conseils de
prud'hommes qui refusait d'appliquer ce
barème en disant que c'était même
contraire aux engagements internationaux
de la france
vous voyez c'est ce dont on parlait
c'était que évidemment certaines
décisions ce qui sont très très
minoritaire conseil des prud'hommes et
blanc de l'édition plutôt idéologique
plutôt que d'appliquer la loi moi je
crois qu'ils sont là pour appliquer la
loi
c'est très bien que la cour de cassation
et puis donnent d'eux puisse donner son
avis la donner maintenant on est dans ce
bar m
qui me semble juste pour te l'ensemble
des partis question de faim avant de
terminer cette émission sylvain maillard
vous avez déposé une proposition de loi
à l'assemblée pour lutter contre l'anti
sionisme résolution proposition de
résolution pour lutter contre l'église
et l'antisémitisme à la fait les frais
d'un débat prolongé sur la réforme de la
du règlement de l'assemblée
est ce qu'elle va revenir à l'ordre du
jour bientôt et quand elle va revenir le
président ferrand s'y est engagé et où
quelques mots et gilles legendre pareil
le président bedie nat normalement début
octobre
il attend une date mais début octobre
tout cas c'est l'engagement position de
résolution pour lutter contre
l'antisémitisme
merci maman merci beaucoup si ma mère
d'avoir participé à cette émission merci
beaucoup katia de leur présenter avec
moi et merci à vous de l'avoir suivi à
très bonne journée et à la semaine
prochaine
ciao
[Musique]
m